and i feel very excited about this new
leaf in life new leaf in life what life
and leaf what how do you say that lease
in life oh my god mom brain
hey guys i'm abby schar welcome to
abby's kitchen so recently i reviewed
freely the banana girls what i eat in a
day video and if you guys missed it you
can check it out right here
so a lot of you guys agree with me that
freelee's diet is anything but balanced
but a few of you chimed in to let me
know that the video that i reviewed to
freelease was actually pretty old and
since then freely's diet has changed so
to be fair to freely i thought i would
review one of her newer videos and let
you know if i think that freely's diet
has in fact changed and improved so
let's do this so when i have orange
juice i don't muck around i have a lot
of orange juice because that is my meal
so i will have anywhere from one and a
half to two and a half liters of orange
juice according to historical data
oranges actually have been eaten for
over four and a half thousand years
drinking orange juice is absolutely a
great way to start the day
so absolutely
i that's a first for me also
seems like a crazy workout to have to
squeeze all those oranges by hand
especially the excessive amount that is
going into this jug at this moment
also i appreciate the little factoids
thank you so much freelee i learned
something new from you so that's great
um but let's talk about this orange
juice situation that she's having for
breakfast now i love me a good glass of
orange juice especially fresh squeezed
but i just can't get behind the idea of
having one and a half to two and a half
liters of orange juice as a meal in one
meal orange juice is not a meal
orange juice on its own is not even a
good snack okay so let's talk about
nutrition for a hot minute here with
just one cup of orange juice you're
going to get 200 of your vitamin c
500 milligrams of potassium and 10 of
your vitamin a for the day
yes orange juice has a lot of health
benefits but you don't need two and a
half liters in order to reap them so
let's pull up the little tally to see
what freelee is getting in this meal if
freelee's consuming two liters of orange
juice she's getting
947 calories
and fifty 1750 of her vitamin c
four thousand two hundred and twenty
seven milligrams of potassium 230 grams
of carbs and 178 grams of sugar so as
you can see here i'm getting up to two
liters there and this orange juice isn't
like super super sweet so i like to add
a little bit of coconut sugar oh no no
no no freely don't do it the richness of
the orange juice and it is healthy in
itself don't let anyone tell you coconut
sugar isn't healthy for you oh my gosh
okay well as if 178 grams of sugar was
not enough
freelee of course has to take it to the
next sugar level by adding a whole ladle
of coconut sugar she says it brings out
the richness of the orange juice but it
also really elevates the sugar and the
carbs and of course the calories
bottom line here freely is consuming
over a thousand calories in this one
meal alone
and it's basically all sugar i mean she
can feel so much more satiated eating
real whole foods and including more
fiber protein and good for you fats
i say this one is a total mess so now
it's lunch and i'm gonna have a
chocolate mint milkshake that's right
you heard right chocolate milkshake and
the base is going to be dates so i'm
putting the dates and i'm having about
20 dates that's how many i usually have
and then add some water at about 1.4 to
1.6 liters of water
and next comes the organic cacao powder
and you want to just start with a
teaspoon or so i put a little bit too
much in and i don't usually even have
this recipe but i thought i'm going to
go a little bit gourmet today and
there's a drop of peppermint oil
and this blended up the chocolate
okay freely not exactly my idea of
gourmet but let's i'm working with you
here so freelee's kicking off this
milkshake lunch with 20 whole dates so
let's bring that tally back up for just
a hot minute so in the dates alone we're
looking at 1300 calories 3 300
milligrams of potassium
360 grams of carbs and a whopping
grams of sugar so then freely proceeds
to add like a liter of water to the
dates making this more like a water
shake not a milkshake let's set the
record straight on that one this is
essentially just watered down dates with
like a little bit of rogue cocoa powder
and peppermint extract added to it and
then she purees the whole thing into a
meal
so let's take a look at the final tally
where we are so far
so before afternoon even hits freely has
eaten scratch that has drank 2
240 calories 7
527 milligrams of potassium 590 grams of
carbs and has hit almost 500 grams of
sugar guys these numbers are crazy
unbalanced to give you a comparison the
typical woman needs between 1500 and 2
000 calories a day
3 500 to 4 700 milligrams of potassium
225 to 325 grams of carbs and 25 to 40
grams of sugar
some of the things that i'm worried
about with friday's diet is the high
sugar intake and the high potassium
intake potassium can do wonders for our
body but having too much or too little
in our blood can actually be deadly high
potassium levels in our blood can lead
to serious issues like muscle weakness
nausea vomiting irregular heartbeat and
trouble breathing this flavor is just
incredible it's really really nice but i
wouldn't recommend it every single day
because cacao can be quite stimulating i
wouldn't recommend it at all really
sorry freely
that's a lot
when you fill an entire pitcher and you
still have like three quarters of your
smoothie to go you know you've overdone
it on the portion size
oh my god
it is making me anxious and like ill
just watching her consume all of this
liquid again i have no qualms about
people enjoying a date milkshake if this
is something that is pleasurable to you
however this whole recipe would probably
feed more like seven to eight people
not just one so we're definitely
overdoing it on the sugar and carbs here
let's move on to dinner i'm excited to
see what she's got going on
i just don't want to watch her drink
anymore please
move along
okay so let's go on to the dinner recipe
yay she's cooking something
this is exciting
oh never mind um this is probably my
last cooked meal oh no freely why you
gotta go back it's our last cooked meal
why why would you torture yourself like
that she's back to raw apparently
so i was i was having some faith and
humanity here i was rooting for her i
was excited about the cooked meal that
i'm seeing here but alas she's going
back to her ways so let's see what she's
making lots of lentils
this delicious style style recipe you
will need lemongrass any type of chili
coriander fresh turmeric this is an
unripe ghost chili which is ridiculously
hot garlic is optional especially if you
are sensitive to it curry leaves ginger
or galangal curry powder sea salt cumin
powder and ground pepper
so i'm loving the the lentils and the
peas there's like lots of good protein
plant-based protein going into this
i'm definitely feeling optimistic
and some vegetables i see some eggplant
i think it's a plantain
maybe some kind of yam or sweet potato
this is great this is awesome i love
this
i've never felt so proud of another
youtuber before
i feel like a strange connection and
when i see her eating something other
than
date water i'm getting really excited
about it
so i'm pretty happy about this we've got
some pulses in there we've got lots of
veggies beautiful spices
some coconut
still it's a little starchy but it is a
way huge improvement compared to the
date water and the sugar down orange
juice that we saw earlier in the day
because we've got some protein in there
with the pulses we've got some fibers i
see some fats from the coconut
yay freely
what i don't love is that she's let our
viewers know that this is her last
cooked meal and i just don't i just
can't comprehend that because this
actually looks delicious and everything
that came before it kind of makes me
want to yak not to mention this is
actually a lot more balanced because
we're getting those fibers we're getting
the protein getting the fat whereas the
rest of the day just sugar just a good
old sugar high
so freely
i would say this is an improvement but
i'm discouraged by your your just last
statement that this is the end this is
the end of the improvement it's all
going back downhill from here so i'm
definitely looking forward to finding
out what you have in store for us down
the road when you are returning back to
raw till four i mean i just don't
understand why you need to kind of go on
and off these fat diets in the first
place my take home message when it comes
to nutrition is of course to listen to
your body try to eat a balanced diet
with a wide range of different foods and
don't go cutting out full food groups
unless it's absolutely necessary
also cook your damn food freely cook it
because we know that a lot of nutrients
are actually more bioavailable when
heated not to mention it's a lot more
appetizing and it's nice to have that
kind of variety in your diet i don't
know about you but chugging two liters
of orange juice does not sound
appetizing to me
so guys i hope you enjoyed this video if
you did be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with some of
your thoughts on some different what i
eat in a day videos that you'd like me
to review subscribe to the channel and
i'll see you next time on abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye you